good morning from Italy film courage my
name is Jay green I'm an amateur
screenwriter I learned a lot through
your different interviews that you have
the teachers I'm a u.s. contractor right
now I'm in Italy I work here at least
for the next year so luckily for me one
of my scenes in my screenplay the 12th
scene is based here at the Vatican so
this is a great opportunity for me I
couldn't ask for anything more I would
say that one of my favorite interviews
is with mr. Martel and him speaking
about getting out there putting your
stuff out there in the community not
something locked up and I do that a lot
but I do take time to come to the
Vatican to get inspired listen watch
people and and work on the dialogue also
be just up another one of my favorites
because she is no BS and she's pretty
rock solid made what my mentor who's out
of New York confirmed she confirmed that
that if you have an idea of somebody
else in the world having that same idea
I've written something and I'm in same
time same location studied everything
down to a running Creek I wrote it in
the same month within 48 hours submitted
it to somebody somebody's mother than I
knew years later and I'm still in Iraq
at the time and I'm telling the story to
somebody and guess what they said that's
actually a play I looked up all the
information person wrote the same month
saying that it was ironic but it but it
happens but one great thing that they
did teach me is that I was on the right
path and even though it wasn't myself
that it was interesting and it became a
number-one play at that time I think it
was in Europe so that confirmed to me
that yeah I was thinking right let's see
where do I hope that my writing takes me
I I don't I don't mind just being a good
writer I'm not looking for saying I just
want to write well write my experiences
give a different outlooks maybe it will
change some people's opinion maybe not
but I like to make my villains a little
bit into the heroes and heroes a little
bit into the villains subsequently I
would say at the end of any of my screen
place that none of them and nobody
they just don't end well but what they
do end with is and with life lesson and
that's what I'm trying to get across I
just really appreciate some courage
because it's the only career other than
what I do right now that can I can close
up in my my bags and you take along with
me if I didn't have that I wouldn't have
my breakfast staple in the morning some
people have cappuccino I have some
courage and a coat that's that's how I
wake up every morning and a lot of times
I'm alone my husband doesn't travel with
me obviously he's not going to go to
Afghanistan Iraq Pakistan and Lebanon so
don't encourage is my best buddy
so keep on doing what you're doing I
appreciate it helps me really water down
and squeeze out all the unnecessary
things in my script I never thought I
could reduce from maybe 150 to 90 pages
but but I have reduced greatly you know
and thank you again